I think what you get is a lot of you
know you get just some text learn from
in those countries they don't have the
luxury of having access to the newer
technologies that come along like with
you know computers you can give a video
you can give an interactive you can give
feedback and right time otherwise these
children are sitting there waiting for
their exams to be given back to them the
results and you know they've lost that
moment where they've been agonizing over
did I do that question right you lose
that thought so there's you know a lot
of so there is a cost in those countries
as well not so much of the cost of the
tech the content but in terms of the
cost of not learning something yes yes
you know not getting that feedback in
time and that's a huge cost in the USA
as well as rest of the world and that
something technology really helps with
so our system can give you feedback
immediately and then also show you what
you did wrong
so if you think about that and saying
versus when you get the exam back back
and then you see that this question
wrong but you don't remember the
struggle don't remember the struggle yes
yes then also the setting up time with
the teacher that's right learn about it
yeah first you've lost that continuty
you know that yes that moment of aha oh
I see what I did wrong because now you
cannot go back to that struggle you hand
not every child you've been wiped it out
the memory human brain is like that that
is probably the coolest thing that I've
learned so far yes that was very
interesting so the moment of when this
is maybe a good example of how to relate
this is by when we are learning directly
from a parent or directly from a boss or
a mentor or a tutor or whoever and when
we're learning directly from them we get
a continuation yes
so when we do something like imagine if
I was paraphrasing what you said yes
then you waited two days yes tell me
what is exactly and imagine you know
imagine learning one thing we know about
learning is that it's additive it just
doesn't happen you know by itself you
have to keep immersing I mean immersing
yourself and learning okay
1 step 2 step 3 step 4 step you know yes
and then suddenly the picture becomes at
some point for different kids the
picture becomes clearer as they learn
more and more and more so imagine a
young kid a child right born they learn
to kind of lift their heads they kind of
get up and they start learning how to
walk right it doesn't happen overnight
it happens in in kind of continuation as
a muscle memory kind of keeps doing
something over and over again you want
to turn around you hear sound you hear
colors I mean you see colors your baby
tries to kind of you know and and
basically it's what the body does over
time
you